durant les années 90 elle était la reine
des émissions pour enfants avec son club
culte ses chansons entêtantes et son
style unique
il s'agit bien entendu de dorothée
absente depuis 24 ans de nos écrans
cette célébrité culte pour toute une
génération a indiqué à plusieurs
reprises qu'elle serait partante pour
faire son retour à la télévision mais
que pour cela il lui faudra le bon
projet la télévision me manque aussi et
j'attends le projet qui saura me séduire
je marche au coup de coeur aujourd'hui
le producteur jean luc azoulay notamment
connu pour hélène et les garçons ou plus
récemment les mystères de l'amour sur
tmc annoncé que dorothée pour avoir
trouvé le projet qui la fera revenir
là on travaille à la voir peut-être dans
une série son retour pourrait bien faire
l'effet d'un tremblement de terre un
typhon sur la mer un grand coup de
tonnerre
voilà de quoi ravir ses plus grands fans
alors dorothée de retour à la télé
trop le mauvais type on est d'accord que
si elle revient leur vient pas pour
faire des missions pour les enfants les
enfants ils vont avoir peur on va
rigoler oui on va demander aux messieurs
où on a hâte qu'elle revienne c'est vrai
que ça fait des années que les fans
l'attendaient plusieurs générations on
est d'accord ça fait presque 15 ans
maintenant qu'elle a disparu des écrans
radar
j'ai 24 ans j'ai reçu et quoi qu'ils
allaient fusionner reçu la semaine
dernière à la radio ou jacky son
comparse du club dorothée ily la seule
chose qui ferait revenir dorothée c'est
un rôle récurrent dans une série
voilà donc c'est très clair là dessus et
elle avait travaillé pour godard dans sa
dans sa jeunesse un oui il ya longtemps
pour god à la longue
évidemment mais en tout cas la même
fibre d'artistes se signer cette semaine
est très bonne comédienne général avec
dorothée je pense tout cela ça nous
rappelle en fait il ya dorothée mais je
crois qu'on revient aussi à des années
qui ont été génial pour nous la jeunesse
manque pas alors si ça me manque
énormément
j'adorerais avoir de voter pour mais
visiblement elle serait en train d' un
peu faire marche arrière parce qu'en
fait on a trop parlé d'elle on s'est
trop avancé sur elle
j'ai cru comprendre le fait que jean luc
azoulay à 10 c'est quasiment signé le
fait que jacky parle de sa vie privée
sur le plateau de de maxime elle dit non
mais en fait moi je suis apparemment que
ce serait ma femme et moi c'est là un
petit peu refroidi à fait normal tant
des dégâts je vois là laissez moi quand
même un petit peu géré mon truc donc on
va encore attendre un petit peu de ce
que j'ai compris que je ne serai mais
elle vient de se marier avec un avec un
fan
n'hésitez pas